hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the ancient u.s rapid knockouts it's
vladislav artemia versus magnus carlson
artemia we've seen how he defeated all
it is it was a really tough struggle and
it took an armageddon to take down
alireza uh whereas magnus had to
duel it out against lavon arunan he was
victorious there and now i'm not gonna
spoil anything for you it's an
incredible game really awesome attacking
one so let's just dive straight into it
artemis has the white pieces and in the
first game he opens with c4 he goes for
the english opening we have knight to f6
by magnus knight to f3 and now c5 so
going for the symmetrical variation
knight to c3 e6 and now e3 uh we have d5
striking in the center uh and d4 now so
basically transposing into the tarash
defense we have a6 and now c captures on
d5 uh we have e captures and now g3
preparing to think it to the light
square bishop c4
now grabbing more space here on the
queen side but the pawn will probably at
some point be undermined with a move
like b3 so bishop to g2 and magnus goes
bishop to b4 we have bishop to d2 and
now uh magnus castles uh and here we
have knights to e5 there is a game uh
where b3 was played uh but here we have
knight to e5 and it is now only as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how how the game
develops we have knight to c6
challenging this knight here on e5 and
magnus sorry our teammate just castles
here saying that okay if you capture
this it's not a problem yes you will
double my pawns here but after i let's
say capture on c3 bishop captures and
knights to e4 i can play queen to d4 and
now what do you play here the knight is
attacked twice you're going to have to
capture capture and now this pawn is
really really weak you're going to have
to play bishop to e6 which kind of you
know
evolves your bishop into a pawn and
after a move like rocated d1 there's
going to be a
a triple attack on this d5 pawn and the
white will be better uh so instead after
this castles we have just rooked to e8
by magnus and now uh artemis captures on
c6 we have knight characters b captures
and now like we said the pawn chain must
be undermined we have b3 uh magnus plays
a5 opens up this well prepares to open
up this diagonal for his light square
bishop and now b captures on c4 so of
course you're not going to capture with
the pawn uh you're going to play bishop
to a6 pinned upon as the rook is on f1
and only after artemis does something
will you capture with the bishop and c
for
not ruining your very nice central pawn
structure so queen to c2 developing the
queen connecting rooks and only now
bishop captures and c4 and now the
bishop player here is very nice but
after rook after b1 magnus decides that
it's time to give up one of the bishops
and he plays bishop captures on c3 which
seems like a justified decision after
bishop captures on c3 artemia does have
the bishop's pair but this dark square
bishop
doesn't really have all that much to do
here the pawns are on dark squares and
uh while this one is a little bit more
placed it's also not doing all that much
so uh that's why probably carlson
decided to do this we have knights the
e4 getting an excellent outpost for his
knight here artemis will never give up
the light square bishop to get rid of
the the this um central knight as it's a
well an important defender the pawns are
on dark square so you need this light
square bishop to keep an eye on the
light squares so bishop back to e1 now
controlling this knight
and magnus starts the attack with h5 now
the idea is h4 you want to open up the
position maybe get the rook into the
attack get to the queen somehow into the
game and good things might happen so
queen to d1 now attacking the pawn here
and the magnus just advances it and here
you could just wait and do nothing try
and play on the queen side or try to get
your pieces into the game but it's not
easy as
well it's just uh
you could play an active move like a
rook to b7 but still it doesn't really
do anything it doesn't attack anything
and there's no way to pile up on it the
magnus will just continue rook to e6
bring rook into the attack and uh you
know the the position will probably
evolve in black's favor so after h4 we
have g4 by artemium he says all right
this pawn for the moment can't really do
anything later i can maybe play h3 and
it's not going to be a very useful pawn
upon advancement so here we have a4 on
the queen side uh now preparing a3 to
grab even more space here and now
artemis plays a3 he doesn't allow magnus
to push a3 but this now gives the b3
square to magnus so he immediately
seizes it bishop to b3 attacks the queen
and also cuts off the rook from uh ever
playing something like rook to b7 and
it's going to be very hard for our team
you have to activate those rooks so
queen to e2 and now rook to e6 uh we
have rook to c1 now artemis putting
pressure on this pawn here but now queen
to g5 and what what can you do here uh
well you have to play something artemia
of course plays f4 why not the pawns are
very nicely advanced here queen back to
e7 and now we have bishop to b4 uh
further harassing this black queen queen
to c7 and now comes f5 attacking uh
carlson's rook here on e6 we have rook e
back to e8 and now queen to e1 going
after this pawn here and now magnus
defends it we have queen to d8 uh and
now this pawn uh is no longer defended
and the defend this mo this pawn magnus
sacrifices this pawn and uh well
although it seems like uh it's a very
useful pawn uh you know things are not
always as they seem so here artemis
captures the pawn plays rook captures on
c6 but now magnus sacrifices yet another
pawn he plays h3 and what can artemia do
here well
other than capturing this pawn there
really isn't a good way to deal with
this you could just move the bishop but
then this pawn just remains here for
free so bishop captures an h3 and now
queen to g5 getting the queen into the
attack so now magnus sacrificed two
pawns and he does have some ideas the
queen now has pressure on e3 it's a
backwards pawn it's not going to be
easily defended once this knight moves
the rook will also help out with the
attack and artemiv has to well has to
play something and the problem for
artemiv is that magnus has some four
minutes on the clock whereas artemis is
starting to drop below one minute so
here we have queen to e2
most likely with the idea of maybe queen
f3 to f4 as he is down two pawns uh we
have rook ate the c8 by magnus attacking
the rook here and now what do you what
do you play here with white well
everyone would probably just play rook a
to c one double up on the c file and try
and force black to exchange on c6 and
that's exactly what artemiev did but
that's uh well that's a blunder that
loses the game uh here you have to
capture for example captures captures
and then continue with your plan queen
f3 queen to f4 but as artemiev was uh
starting to get very low on the clock he
played rook eight to see one first now
with uh
a double attack on the rook and c8 but
like i said this loses the game for him
so feel free to pause the video and win
the first game of the finals for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
disconnecting move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop the c4 this is what artemis
missed and that's why you had to
absolutely had to capture on c8 now the
rooks are disconnected they're not
defending each other and now the threat
is uh we're either going to capture the
rook or we're going to capture the queen
and giving up a full rook the magnus
doesn't really do anything for you sort
him if it does the only thing that's
left and that's trying to play without a
queen he plays rook captures on c8
magnus captures the queen and now rook
captures the other rukhani eight with
check so now artemis has two rooks for
the queen but the problem is magnus
already has the attack and the bishop
knight and queen are already surrounding
the white king so king to h7 and now
bishop back to d2 defending the e3 pawn
uh and trying to sacrifice the bishop
here but grabbing this bishop would be a
pretty bad idea because if magnus goes
for this then artemis has this rook a to
c8 and then rook to h8 is coming okay
black will not get checkmated you can
avoid getting checkmated with a move
like g6 but still black will be happy to
escape with a draw here we're going to
play f captures on g6 now you really
can't counter because of checkmate or
you capture with the king and then we
pick up uh
your queen after this check is given so
you'd have to play something like this
then we're going to capture here threat
and promotion then after king captures
rook fade to check and we're gonna
well uh just uh
harass the black king forever and uh uh
get at least a draw uh but magnus
doesn't fall for this bishop to d2 plan
he plays bishop captures on g4 and now
he's threatening uh a lot of very nasty
discoveries artemis king is still on g1
so bishop to g2 was played but now just
bishop to f3 threatening checkmate and
he was in this position unmoved 35 that
vladislav artemia resigned the game and
the game one goes to magnus as well
there's really nothing more to be done
here you could stall and prolong the
game a few more moves but other than
that that's that's pretty much it
uh so
really impressive and i just realized i
forgot to turn on my little light so i
could be a bit darker in this video but
i i don't think you guys mind you you
guys are here for the chess
so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank uh
or rather wish happy birthday to sharok
uh thank christopher alexander sopa tom
derelo cakedefy.com and davinci natale
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this amazing
finals between these two fine gentlemen
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day